how's it going everybody it's Lauren and
last weekend at CC XP Kevin Feige
revealed new footage for Black Widow and
the Eternals sadly nothing was revealed
about phase 5 any future Avengers movies
or any future crossovers that Marvel
might have coming up however that does
not mean that Marvel doesn't have some
big Avengers movie or big crossover
event coming up in fact immediately
after Marvel's panel at cc XP Kevin
Feige was an interview and he talked
about a future crossover event that is
coming up for Marvel Studios and he also
talked about his plans for each solo
film and solo TV series that is coming
to the MCU as well so let's break down
what he said in this interview but first
a quick reminder to subscribed with
notifications turned on like the video
and comment below to enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or ps4
so like I mentioned after the panel at
CC XP Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios in an interview talked
about the prospect of another huge team
up movie like Avengers endgame so not
just another Avengers movie but a huge
crossover like Avengers endgame was now
he did say that a plan is already
underway for a big crossover event which
is exciting but also not really
surprising as well in-game was such a
very huge event and we have a ton of new
characters available to Marvel to use in
the MCU it's only a matter of time until
we get another Avengers in-game level
event nobody really knows when it's
probably not too soon but Kevin Feige
has assured us that plans are in place
but at the same time he did state and
emphasized in this interview that
they're going to focus on delivering
exceptional experiences with each
individual movies release basically
stating that with each movie they put
out they want to make it the best they
can absolutely make it so black widows
coming out they want to make it the best
Black Widow movie as possible rather
than focusing on making the movie
connect to a huge crossover event years
down the road not to mention the MCU has
to establish new avengers before they
can even introduce the new avengers in
the interview he said the MCU is all
interconnected but we really focus on
one movie at a time we're going to make
the best black widow movie we can
possibly make the best Eternals movie we
can make the best shang-chi the best
Doctor Strange Thor Captain Marvel black
panther and keep evolving their stories
but then he said then
yes it is always fun to see them come
together in a master plan which is I
promise you well underway so as you just
heard Kevin Feige stated himself in this
interview that a huge crossover event
where all of these new characters come
together is already being planned and is
already well underway now it's been
speculated that we probably won't be
getting another huge event like Avengers
in game for at least another ten years
however if we take a look at phase four
it's actually not as long as phase three
was the movies that were in phase three
spanned over three years long and the
movies in phase four only go for two
years and we can probably expect phase
five to do the same so that would mean
phase four and phase five together would
only make four years so if they were
going to do a pretty big event after
phase five we'd only have to wait about
four years for this and even if they
went with what they did for the Infinity
saw got releasing three phases and then
the big crossover event at the end of
phase three we'd still only have to wait
about six years if they decide to keep
each face - only two years and again
like I just said Kevin Feige said that
this plan is well underway already and
it seems like in this interview he could
have possibly stated who the new
Avengers team could be and who's going
to be involved in this next new huge
crossover now Black Widow of course is
dead and unless they're planning to use
Deol in a Bulova as Black Widow she's
probably not going to be in the New
Avengers team so the New Avengers team
is most likely going to be shang-chi
Doctor Strange Thor Captain Marvel Black
Panther and then of course any more new
superheroes that they introduced along
the way and of course you know we have
to include Spidey in there as well but
the Eternals are really a group of their
own so they're most likely not going to
be a part of the New Avengers team
however one the big crossover event
happens you can bet they're going to be
there because later on and the interview
Kevin Feige stated that the Eternals
know who the Avengers are and the
Eternals are going to show events from
the past of the MCU
his exact quote is the Eternals know
about the existence of the Avengers
The Avengers don't know much about the
Eternals yet so he's implying that this
new Avengers team is going to know about
the Eternals so they'll most likely be
included in a new crossover event where
the heroes have to defend the galaxy
after all it's the job of the Eternals
to defend earth so that's something
we'll have to figure out in the Eternals
why they didn't show up when Thanos
was there when Ultron was there when
Loki came with fan s's army hopefully
this is all going to be addressed when
the Eternals comes out but there you
have it in this interview Kevin Feige
has confirmed a huge crossover event is
already in the works and being planned
and a new Avengers team is coming let me
know what you think this huge crossover
event is going to be like and let me
know who you'd like to see on the new
Avengers team let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and also
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 you can also click the link in
the description down below for a chance
to win an Infinity Gauntlet don't forget
to use code cosmic @ G fuel comm for 30%
off G fuel and as always thank you all
so much for watching
willful off